to announce the nominees for outstanding
animated short films and dramatic
live-action short films a great comic
actor and a great Kidder Ellen Arkin and
Margot Kidder
yes Margo how short is a short film a
short film is 3000 fearless AHA so a 90
feet a minute that's about thirty three
point three minutes and I've known some
acceptance speeches that were longer
than that the nominees for outstanding
at achievement and animated short films
are all nothing frederik back producer
the fly friends refuse producer history
of the world in three minutes flat
Michael Mills producer and the winner is
the winner is the fly friends refuse
producer
Academy excuse me the Academy would like
to congratulate friends refused and
accepts this award on his behalf so
congratulations wait a minute
I'm sorry get the invitation to Leigh
and I thanks in his name and just one
word even the short film can be great
and now congratulations are also an
order for the following nominees for
outstanding achievement in dramatic
live-action short films the dollar
bottom lloyd phillips producer Fraulein
barb Carmichael and Gregg Lowe producers
a jury of her peers Sally heckle
producer and the winner is the dollar
bottom lloyd phillips producer
I'm deeply honored to accept this award
on behalf of everybody who worked on the
film and especially on behalf of a very
talented director Roger Christian thank
you very much and thank you also to
Paramount Pictures Jeff Katzenberg and
the Installer for making this film
possible thank you
as Johnny told you tonight's telecast of
the Academy Awards is being beamed to an
audience of over 300 million people in
65 countries throughout the world and in
the spirit of friendship that exists in
the movie industry Allen thought that it
might be appropriate at this time to
greet all our movie-going friends around
the globe yes I did
let's start with the A's Albania Mira
Bruna douche more filmer Algeria Akuma
Ana wet as cinema whom the humble [ __ ]
indulges cinema argentinas buenos noches
aficionados del cine Austria was an
average man adamant in here bill coming
from the economy intolerable
you
Richard Chamberlain Peter
[ __ ] Spacek and Billy Dee Williams
we'll continue in a moment